nous sommes samedi 3 juin à l'heure où
j'écris cette vidéo et je viens de
sortir du cinéma des images et des
questions plein la tête
oui je suis allé voir pirates des
caraïbes 5 la vengeance de salazar je
préfère prévenir davance si je veux
traiter les théories sur ce film je vais
bien évidemment spoil donc voilà c'est
dit bref attaquons le morceau ce film
m'a réellement perturbé car déjà pas mal
d'erreurs ont été commises afin de
suivre la cohérence des films mais de
nombreux mystères sont encore présents
jack sparrow va rencontrer le fils de
will turner henry qui aura besoin de son
aide pour trouver le trident de poséidon
qui peut défaire toutes les malédictions
existantes dans le monde
jack en aura même besoin car un ancien
capitaine du nom de salazar voudra se
venger de lui c'est un mort vivant donc
une malédiction un des fers suite à la
mort de ce dernier dans le triangle des
bermudes ce triangle est vraiment un
élément perturbateur de la saga la scène
post générique aussi d'ailleurs
bref on ne va pas s'attarder plus
longtemps dans l'introduction de cette
vidéo sachez que cette théorie ont
toutes été imaginées par moi même c'est
une vidéo 100% subjective
alors voici les trois théories que je
vous propose
[Musique]
davy jones est de retour c'est un fait
si vous êtes restés après les crédits de
fin de film
vous avez forcément vu la scène où will
turner dort profondément aux côtés de sa
bien-aimée elizabeth swann cependant à
naître entre dans la pièce un être
plutôt familier cela réveille will et
tout d'un coup la scène nous répond avec
le vrai réveil de will ayant fait un
cauchemar
cependant la caméra descend et montre
des petits coquillages
cette scène n'est pas là par hasard et
questionne énormément de choses tout
d'abord l'être entrant dans la pièce est
bien évidemment davy jones l'ancien
capitaine du hollandais volant auquel
will a pris la place son thème et même
jouer à la fin quand les coquillages
sont filmés ceci annonce son retour pour
les prochaines opus de pirates des
caraïbes
alors voilà l'objet du débat et ce
fameux trident rompant toutes les
malédictions même celle du hollandais
volant
d'après ce que nous montre le film ceci
va d'ailleurs perturber grandement les
films mais nous en parlerons plus tard
pour vous rappeler le capitaine du
hollandais volant doit s'arracher le
coeur elle enfermée dans un coffre et
est condamné à errer sur les mers et ne
peut revenir que sur terre une fois tous
les dix ans car il a pour mission de
guider les âmes des marins défunt vers
l'au delà
cependant voilà c'est une mission et non
une malédiction
la malédiction et la forme tentaculaire
de davy jones
mais comment cela se fait-il qu'il soit
encore sous cette forme malgré le tri
d'or il faut savoir que cette
malédiction et créent de l'amour d'un
marin et d'une ds bien évidemment je
parle de calypso dsd maire qui fut
libérée lors du troisième film cependant
nous parlons d'une ds la ds qui contrôle
les mers des caraïbes et du monde c'est
calypso qui a donné la mission de guider
les hommes à davy jones et c'est une
mission capitale qui ne peut être rompu
par le trident de poséidon même si
poséidon est un dieu des mers cette
mission est capital dans le monde de
pirates des caraïbes
l'hollandais volant doit toujours avoir
un capitaine cependant oui les libérer
du navire fantôme et n'a plus à
s'occuper de cette mission cependant
personne ne tue et will donc cela
voudrait dire que davy jones ait été
ressuscitée par calypso pour mener à
bien cette mission de base
il a prêté allégeance autrefois et
fidélité par amour cette scène post
générique est un réel fan service est
pour elles ont raconté que des lits john
soir venu certainement prendre la clé du
coffre où il ya le coeur de will pendant
son sommeil
les coquillages filmé par terre avec le
thème de davy jones nous annonce son
retour c'est sur le prochain film
tournera donc autour de delhi john
certainement pour expliquer sa forme
tentaculaire qui normalement aurait dû
s'arrêter suite à la destruction du
trident de poséidon la réponse serait
que calypso et la déesse des mers des
caraïbes
le hollandais volant est d'ailleurs la
mission qu'elle a donnée à davy jones
elle est au même titre que poséidon dieu
des océans
ce n'est pas une malédiction comme les
autres c'est un petit peu tiré par les
cheveux car c'est entre guillemets une
erreur du film car le hollandais volant
redevient d'ailleurs un magnifique
bateau donc même si davy jones a été
ramené par calypso par exemple il
devrait avoir une forme humaine car il
n'est plus lié aux landais volant est
n'est plus sous sa malédiction
je ne vais pas vous le cacher davy jones
et mon personnage préféré dans pirates
des caraïbes et j'ai envie de vous
donner une autre vision de la dernière
cène vous vous souvenez bien de la scène
post générique nous voyons l'ombre de
davy jones en forme de calamars est et
nous voyons même sa pince cependant
quand will se rend compte que c'est un
cauchemar la caméra sous tendent vers le
sol et nous apercevons des coquillages
ce passage pourrait réellement
symboliser la fin de la malédiction du
hollandais volant
le cauchemar montrant que debbie jones
revient reprendre sa place de capitaine
car le navire fantôme doit toujours
avoir un capitaine mais que le réveil de
will avec les google cars ter confirmés
et celle cette malédiction maintenant
détruit par le tri dans les coquillages
décoller serait soit une trace du
passage de davy jones soit qu'ils se
sont tout simplement décollée de lui
pour dire qu'il retrouve sa forme
humaine suite à la fin de la malédiction
cette hypothèse est tout de même
probable mais étant un fan de davy jones
si disney a décidé de le montrer à la
fin c'est qu'il doit être revenu et
c'est ce que je pense sincèrement davy
jones serait certainement ramener pour
accomplir la mission de guider les âmes
vers l'au delà
mais sous forme humaine qu'il pourrait
enfin vivre normalement et non plus
comme un esclave du bateau pour finir il
faut savoir que jack a dit qu'il avait
rendez vous au bout des mers donc
possiblement un rapport avec le goût du
monde comme énoncé dans le troisième
opus avec l'antre de débit jones mais
nous allons en reparler dans les
prochaines théorie cette théorie est un
petit peu fouillis je m'en excuse mais
j'ai tellement réfléchi sur ce passage
je voulais vraiment le traité sous tous
les angles
[Musique]
si vous ne le saviez pas l'histoire de
pirates des caraïbes s'inspire toujours
de célèbre légende pirates
la légende du navire fantôme guidant les
morts vers l'au-delà parle bien
évidemment du hollandais volant avec
davy jones aux commandes c'est la
légende pirates la plus connue avec
celle aussi de barbe noire à pirate
sanguinaire qui faisait régner la
terreur sur les mers pirates des
caraïbes 5 s'inspire aussi de légende à
celle du triangle des bermudes avec les
nombreuses disparitions de bateaux et
l'histoire du corsaire à rolando salazar
qui est un célèbre capitaine espagnol
ce sont toutes des histoires vraies mais
quelle légende pourraient être utilisés
pour la suite de pirates des caraïbes
pour le sixième opus
et bien après de nombreuses recherches
j'ai trouvé une légende qui conviendrait
parfaitement à la situation
je m'explique tout d'abord rappelons
nous des dernières phrases de jack
sparrow
nous allons suivre les étoiles j'ai
rendez vous des mères avec mon horizon
d'amour jack a prévu de suivre les
étoiles et non une carte
donc il faut déjà une légende rapport
avec les étoiles comme pour le trident
ensuite il parle du bout des mers donc
un endroit loin d'où il est actuellement
puis l'horizon d'amour je pense que jack
parle de son destin ou bien d'un endroit
qu'ils l'aiment et je pencherais pour
notre beau pays la france jack sparrow
aime beaucoup la france
pourquoi je vais vous parler de la
légende du cryptogramme de la bu ce
célèbre pirate français
ce pirate avant de mourir sous la
guillotine jeter un papier dans la foule
en criant mon trésor à qui saura
comprendre ce papier est un cryptogramme
indéchiffrable cachant son immense
trésors rempli de diamants et autres
joaillerie et ce cryptogramme est encore
un mystère aujourd'hui c'est une légende
qui fait encore parler d'elle de nos
jours et personne n'a jamais réellement
réussi à déchiffrer ce message
entièrement le bus de son vrai nom
olivier levasseur était un pirate très
célèbre et son trésor était immense je
vais prendre ici que les faits en
rapport avec l'univers de pirates des
caraïbes
car c'est un mystère réellement complexe
dans l'histoire des pirates alors
d'après les nombreuses interprétations
du cryptogramme par des historiens ou
autres chercheurs la lettre y de la
première ligne du cryptogramme
symboliserait lama du canard sauvage
d'interprétation expliquerait la
première ligne du cryptogramme qui
pourrait se traduire prenez une paire de
pigeons d'après les astronomes l'amas
stellaire du canard sauvage
ressemblerait à un vol d'oiseaux
migrateurs et la paire de pigeons
décrite dans le cryptogramme de la buse
symboliserait les deux oiseaux de tête
du vol migrateurs la halle et y de la
troisième ligne du cryptogramme
symboliserait l'étoile al-fath kuti la
laiterie g de la 6e ligne du
cryptogramme symboliserait l'étoile
delta sweety le signe de la ligne 14 du
cryptogramme s'apparentant à un y
entouré de deux points symboliserait
l'étoile gamas kuti je ne vais pas vous
citer toutes les étoiles interprété dans
le cryptogramme
mais vous devez vous rendre compte de
l'étendue de ce mystère et dur rapport
avec les étoiles afin de trouver ce
trésor grec parle bien de suivre les
étoiles est depuis toujours cherche des
richesses comme tout bon pirate qui se
respecte jack pourrait être à la
poursuite du trésor de la buse d'où le
cryptogramme qui se réfère aux étoiles
et aux constellations
le trésor pourrait bien se situer dans
un endroit en rapport avec l'ama du
canard sauvage un hamac contenant plus
de trois mille étoiles comme dans
pirates des caraïbes 5
jack devra étudier des étoiles pour
trouver le trésor puis pour continuer
dans le fan service que propose pirates
des caraïbes
vous ne trouvez pas que le pirate la
buse ressemble à un pirate déjà
existants dans l'univers de pirates des
caraïbes
je parle du capitaine teague gardien du
code pirate joué par caisse richard's et
père de jack sparrow
ce pirate lui ressemble comme deux
gouttes d'eau quand il était jeune et
nous ne savons rien sur l'histoire de
famille de jack et de son père dans
l'histoire de pirates des caraïbes
il se pourrait que ce trésor soit cachée
par capitaine teague et qu'il soit mort
dans le sixième opus
après tout est ce rite charte se fait
vieux et son personnage joué aussi et
cela pourrait débloquer énormément de
choses car dans l'histoire de pirates
des caraïbes il faut savoir que jack a
une soeur et oui katrina sparrow si vous
voulez tout savoir une corsair devenu
pirate
il se pourrait fortement que jack la
retrouve dans ce sixième opus qui
tournerait autour d'une histoire de
famille
et puis d'ailleurs pourquoi pas sous les
ordres davy jones comme pirate katrina
sparrow pourrait avoir rejoint
l'équipage de débit jones qui fera son
retour prochainement cela promettrait un
pirate des caraïbes réellement épique et
un très bon retour aux sources et je
suis fier d'avoir imaginé toute cette
théorie a vous de me dire ce que vous en
pensez dans les commentaires je pense
que c'est la théorie a pu pousser que je
n'ai jamais pensé ou réalisés et
j'espère qu'elle vous aura plu
passons à la dernière théorie toujours
en rapport avec les dernières phrases de
jack
nous allons suivre les étoiles j'ai
rendez-vous des mères avec mon horizon
d'amour voici les dernières phrases de
jack sparrow lors du cinquième opus de
pirates des caraïbes et que pourrait
bien vouloir dire ses phrases eh bien je
pencherais pour un avis amoureux pour
tout vous expliquer déjà avant que jack
prononce ses phrases il était moins des
embrassades d'elisabeth et de will
ils étaient moins de leurs retrouvailles
et de leur amour pareil pour henry et
karina qui finalement trouvé l'amour
ensemble suite à l'histoire du film jack
est témoin de tout ça et c'est à ce
moment qu'il prononce ces mots avec un
champ lexical de l'amour étoiles rendez
vous horizon d'amour on pourrait même
rajouter le mot maire de au bout des
mères car jackée profondément amoureux
de la mer le terme de boue des mers
pourrait symboliser au bout du monde là
où elles entrent de davy jones cela
voudrait dire que jack pourrait aller
chercher quelqu'un ou quelque chose là
bas si on reste dans le délire amoureux
il se pourrait qu'il aille chercher
angelica qui fut laissée à l'abandon par
jack dans le quatrième opus ou bien
barbossa son confrère pirates et rival
de toujours qui se sacrifia pour sauver
sa fille carine à j'essaie de rester en
rapport avec davy jones car il est sûr à
90% minimum qu'il fasse son retour dans
le prochain opus de pirates des caraïbes
jacques parle de suivre les étoiles et
barbossa avait l'air de beaucoup s'y
connaître à ce sujet d'après ce que nous
montre le film jack pourrait aller
chercher barbossa déjà pour rendre sa
dette
car il ne faut pas oublier que barbosa
est allé chercher jack dans l'antre de
davy jones et puis car il aurait besoin
de lui pour une nouvelle quête en
rapport avec les étoiles ou autres
constellation les dernières phrases de
jack sont réellement énigmatique car le
fait de parler du bout des mères avec
son horizon d'amour peut signifier aussi
le futur de jack quelque chose en
rapport avec son avenir son destin le
fait de retrouver angelica dans l'au
delà
si elle est morte évidemment ce n'est
pas sûr est une possibilité qu'il ne
faut pas négliger
angelica possède des liens avec jack des
liens amoureux
il se pourrait même qu'elle ait donné
naissance d'un enfant qui serait de jack
après tout
un fils avec elisabeth même barbossa
maintenant une fille
il est fortement possible que jack est
une descendante dans les prochains films
il ne faut pas oublier que maintenant
toutes les malédictions été rompu par la
destruction du trident donc les pirates
des caraïbes avec des hommes poissons
morts vivants et j'en passe sont
terminées vous m'envoyez navré mais
c'est ce que disney nous laisse penser
je vous remercie en tout cas d'avoir
suivi cette vidéo j'espère que mes
théories vous auront plus pirates des
caraïbes est une saga qui me fait rêver
depuis mon enfance et je suis un réel
fans de davy jones qui est l'un de mes
antagonistes préférées malheureusement
d'après moi à l'époque de pirates des
caraîbes 2 et 3 est maintenant loin la
scène post générique mme hype réellement
mais j'ai peur que cela soit du remâché
davy jones est mort et ceux normalement
pour toujours merci à ceux qui
laisseront un pouce bleus et qui
partageront cette vidéo on en est à rgo
rock
je suis le lane earth et je suis
l'esclave du hollandais volant
[Musique]